les yeux rivés sur son ordinateur ses
oreilles grandes ouvertes
amira écoutent la radio tout en
cuisinant depuis fin mars radio corona
international mg et en direct sur le
réseau social facebook
deux fois par semaine le mardi et le
vendredi
ses chroniqueurs s'exprime sans contenir
leurs mots et c'est justement ce qui
plaît les chroniqueurs parlent eux
librement ils parlent de ce qu'ils
veulent quand ils veulent
il n'y a pas de limite c'est ça dont on
a besoin déjà nous avons un tel manque
de liberté il nous arrive d'être surpris
lorsqu'on entend quelqu'un parler
librement et ça nous fait du bien
parmi les sujets abordés la crise du
corona virus bien sûr mais avec le plus
d'humour possible
le harcèlement de rue la psychologie la
culture mais aussi la politique et la
répression
pour autant d'après abdallah benadouda
son fondateur exilé aux états unis
ce n'est pas un média contestataires
mais une radio qui dit simplement les
choses telles qu'elles sont pas de corps
un terme à son balai pour la vérité on
dire la vérité on est en étable en
assume le fait d'être un média qui est
née de la contestation de la révolution
du 22 février donc nous sommes il est un
peu une émanation de réinvention d'irak
autant de la en débit à ce conte et
anti-régime clôturait conclut régime de
béré tu en es anti régime
les choses sont bien faites en le 10 mai
mais oui on est on est pro algérien on
est on est des algériens ses
chroniqueurs sont un peu partout alger
boumerdès et oran en algérie mais aussi
au québec ou encore à paris depuis la
capitale française
azzedine mihoubi anime la minute théâtre
et pour lui sa participation à radio
corona international est un moment qu'il
ne raterait
pour rien au monde en fait elle est
importante pour donner espoir pour
parler de justice pour parler au nom des
opprimés pour parler au nom des
prisonniers d'opinion
en fait cette radio las une bouffée
d'air de liberté et j'ai l'impression de
participer aux combats
j'ai l'impression d'être utile de le
donner en fait un peu de moi en étant
loin c'est ça la magie des réseaux
sociaux en fait continuer à se parler
alors que le confinement impose le
silence aux algériens radio corona
international leur permet de se
retrouver comme il le faisait pendant
les manifestations du miracle une
manière de garder un oeil sur leur pays